adjustable rate mortgages it's one of
the biggest rip-offs ever to come along
ensures that the lender is always going
to freaking make money
according Mouse too this is a bank play
it ain't got anything to do with being a
blessing to you in allowing according to
experience help prospective buyers get
their foot in the door bull crap hadn't
got anything to do with prospective
buyers it's got to do with banks and one
thing you can count on banks is Banks
protecting Banks it's what they do and
they've been good at it for a long time
that's why their Furniture is nicer than
yours that's why their building is
bigger than yours
it's not an accident Santa Claus didn't
build those freaking Towers in the
skyline
it was you you built them with this kind
of crap where you give these Banks your
money you fall for the Trap of this
stuff